good morning John you just got back to
America from Jordan and Tunisia where
you visited refugee camps and I'm really
looking forward to any thoughts you
might have from those places in the
meantime hear from my very safe location
in Missoula Montana I want to talk about
the government of America is a mess
right we've heard that it's a mess not
to talk about politics right now which
is I just don't want to talk about that
I'm talking about the federal government
that massive inefficient bureaucracy
that does something nobody really knows
what we're spending a lot of money
nothing's getting done so that's that's
the idea that we have in our heads well
I'm going to take kind of a radical
position in this video and say that the
federal government is effective
efficient and surprisingly small I
recently asked my followers on Twitter
some questions about government
employees how many there are at the
state level the local level the federal
level in military education that kind of
asked those questions because I had
looked this information up and found
myself to be quite surprised by what a
fact pretty much everybody including me
thought they were roughly the same
number of federal and state and local
government employees state and local
governments employ more than 7 million
people and that's not including
education the federal government employs
less than 3 million people fewer people
also dramatically overestimated the
number of uniformed military we have and
dramatically underestimated the number
of people who work in public education
which is by far the largest category of
government employee more than 7 million
people work in public education but
here's the truly remarkable statistic
that I couldn't even believe when I
first read it over the last 50 years the
number of federal government employees
has increased by less than zero percent
it has decreased it hasn't decreased a
lot but it has not gone up so if the
budget is increasing the economy is
growing the number of people in the
country has increased by more than 100
million and the number of employees that
manage this government has not gone up
is it any wonder that it seems difficult
to deal with the federal government
there's more to manage and we're using
the same number of people to manage it
so the budget has increased dramatically
but the number of people were paying
hasn't what's going on first a lot of it
spent on contractors so that's when the
government gives money to a private come
to do things for it whether that's goods
or services it could be like a
janitorial company just cleaning up
office buildings or it could be Lockheed
Martin building fighter jets that all
adds up to about five hundred billion
dollars that's more than the federal
government pays for its own employees
but still the budget is more than three
trillion dollars where's all that money
going we give it away sixty-four percent
of the money the government spent this
year was spent on Social Security
Medicare Medicaid poverty assistance and
veterans benefits sixty-four percent is
you take out all of that stuff state and
local governments actually spend
significantly more than the federal
government politicians talk about
skyrocketing spending and government
bureaucratic inefficiency but those two
things have nothing to do with each
other by rocketing costs have far more
to do with demographic trends and
increases in health care costs than they
do with bureaucracy so if you're
watching this try to keep these things
in your head the number of government
employees hasn't increased in the last
50 years and those people do really good
important work and they're pretty good
at state and local governments have a
huge effect on the lives of people
living there and they actually employ
far more people than the federal
government and those elections are
extremely important by far the largest
category of government employee is the
teacher and a significant majority of
the money the federal government spends
is spent to help out old people and sick
people and people who are very poor and
people who risk their lives to protect
this country John I'll see you on
Tuesday